Một mời của tổng thống Mỹ đưa năng trang ngày mì sọ tháng tâm, lánh giống sự thay đổi quan trọng,
trăm lập trường của Washington về chính sử của khói nè, thay vì tụng nhấn mạnh một tiêu đọt được lệnh bắn,
ông Trump trần rằng điều cân thiết là một thỏa thuận hoa bình toàn diện có hả năng giải quyết các mùi nhấn gấp dễ của sinh độ.
Theo ông lệnh bắn thường không theo dài và khó bảo đam tính mình vẫn trường bất cảnh đối đầu quân sự hiện này.
Lòng thấy này dễ dàng ai sau như thượng định ngà Mỹ tại Alaskan,
nơi ông Trump và tổng thống Ngà Đor đi Mepu Chien thảo lận hơn 3 tiếng năm hồ,
khu gặp đơn xam là bất khởi đầu đẻ 2 cân có tìm giếm lỗi thoát cho cuộc khủng khoảng.
Chúng khi đó, kia vẫn sử lập trường, kia nguyết bác bảo để sân dức khỏi gùng trong bác nhiều phía nha đơn xa.
Giờ qua sinh nhấn định thay đổi của tổng thống Trump và nánh mong muốn Mỹ đong phá trò chung tâm trong việc kiến tạo dài pháp phóa bình,
thay vì chỉ tụng đầy keb hiện pháp ngắn hạn, đây có thể là bất chuyển quan trọng,
nhưng con được nghĩ để một trà thận cuối cùng và con nhiều trí thức.